Vietnam is known for having some of the world's most amazing cuisine,...
...and today we are going on a cooking class tour to learn...
...how to make some of it for ourselves.
So the tour starts by meeting up with your group.
Then you're going to head to a local market...
...to pick up ingredients for the cooking class.
Half the fun of a tour like this is coming to a market...
...where you get to see the food from around the world...
...that people are eating.
Oh my gosh.
We left the market.
We have all of our ingredients,...
...and a few steps away is the kitchen for our cooking class.
Oh! This is so beautiful.
Hello everybody.
Welcome to Rose Kitchen.
Our first dish, we're preparing a salad.
You cook a variety of dishes,...
...and they can accommodate dietary requirements.
It's a small group of no more than ten people.
Now we're preparing bun cha, which is an iconic Vietnamese dish.
It's barbecue pork.
Okay, let's eat.
I'm going to try the salad.
This is banana flower.
So good.
We did a good job.
That's one of the best things I've ever eaten.
I'm in absolute heaven.
And it's a good thing I'm eating with chopsticks...
...because it's slowing me down.
This is probably one of the best meals I've ever had.